sarah joins us to start off this hour in
Cleveland Ohio
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Sarah
hello hi what's up so we have to leave
the cars and we pay way too much money
like seven hundred seventy-five dollars
a month for the two of them my original
phone of course was to pay his hey at
them off or sell them but since we have
like 20 months left on them I'm trying
to decide like so we take our extra cash
and hey the cars off early and then get
rid of them or do we take that extra
cash and we save it for when the leases
are up so that we can actually purchase
cars well the idea would be so you're
not going to keep these at the end of
the lease is what you're saying you're
not going to have the money to pay them
off at any time the process okay so what
you do is you find out what the what the
buyout number is at the end of the lease
yes so I did that how about that did you
find out the buyout now yes
so we're upside down on both of these
rooms about $6,000 sure that's not the
point okay so the point is you're gonna
write if you sell the car today you
found out what it's worth today and what
it would take to pay it off today
correct okay what's in that difference
is $6,000
correct okay 20 and is it $700 a month
each no altogether 75 okay what is what
is one of them one is 401 is 375 okay so
400 you know basically we're comparing
if you keep it for 20 months what it
costs you and then you turn it in right
or if you sell it today we know what it
costs you if you sell it today it cost
you $6,000 right right okay if you keep
it 20 months 400 times 20 would be
$8,000 alright and so but you get the
use of the car for $2000 for 20 months
so and it's kind of on the bubble I'd
probably sell it okay now the other one
was how much it's 375
and 20 months left on that yeah and is
it 6,000 in the hole - it's about five
okay so it's on the bubble - same a same
equation 375 times 20 months is going to
be more than five thousand dollars but
not a lot more it's probably going to be
seven thousand dollars or whatever and
don't yet in my head or put in the
calculator but you see what I'm doing so
yeah I think the advantage to you is to
be free of this mess and that might be
worth a little bit of money for sure
you're saving money the only question is
by selling the mail the question is are
you saving enough to justify the loss of
the car for 20 months and that's the
part that's on the bubble but you've got
such a mess you probably just need to
dump both of them
hey okay so get rid of it's that simple
get them sold borrow the 6,000 or 5,000
that's 11,000 and you got to get
probably borrow a little bit more to get
a little bit of get you a couple of
beaters to drive around while you clean
this mess up and the good news is is
that once you're done you're done you
know it's not it's over you don't have
to do this like 20 times but if you'll
Drive like no one else later you can
drive like no one else we don't tell
people to drive junk cars their entire
life we tell them to drive junk cars
when they're broke and then when you're
not broke him or get you a better car
and then when your millionaire if you
want to get a new car get a new car but
pay cash for it all along don't be
driving stuff you can't afford and by
the way the definition of driving
something you can't afford partly is you
didn't pay for it yet payments on it by
definition you couldn't afford it I got
the money in the bank to pay it off then
pay it off but 99% of people say they
have a payment means they bought a car
that they couldn't pay off